this is unbelievable I know I tell you I
first walked in I freaked I immediately
felt like I was back on stage five at
Paramount and I was really on our set
it's perfect just six months ago
here's during construction and this is
the big reveal tell us a secret about
what you remember shooting here in this
living room set one thing or one thing
that maybe we didn't see on TV magic
tricks up here the original set this one
is original like you know some of it has
been recreated like this sofa because
they couldn't find that fabric I just
remember running up and down the stairs
mm-hmm it didn't go anywhere
[Music]
somewhere bedrooms are on the second
floor they veterans are bedrooms on the
set we're right outside that door one of
the things that I will never forget is
those kisses from Davy Jones so jokes
I mean desi and Davy and Marion Ross
came through that door as a doctor and
Joe Namath
I mean we had amazing people on our show
we want to see you back together on TV
again could there be like a special or
could there be beyond the HGTV I was
going to say well this is it for now
this is gonna this is for now right now
and we could film it here in live here
yeah well I you know drive that old car
from 1972 we could do the talk show here
and freak out our guests and they'd be
unable to speak wouldn't that be good
yeah cuz when you first walk in you
freaked out to make this iconic house
complete it took no fewer than
six TV siblings and twin HGTV stars this
is the most complex the largest
residential renovation we have ever done
and there was one very important detail
that was added for the first time on the
Brady show they never showed a toilet
because it was taboo to show a toilet on
the show so for the first time ever the
Brady's have toilets and you wouldn't
believe what went into creating these
entryway stones we actually sketched it
from what we saw on TV and then we got
projector and projected that on to the
wall we made them exactly the same size
and color so that with the same the
hardest detail to duplicate the
staircase we will show you that
unbelievable reveal a little later it
was a challenge because they had to make
this one-story house into two okay so
this was a feat of engineering you
cannot change that iconic roofline what
are we gonna do we dug down so he went
lower yes so when you walk in the door
you actually step down into the family
room and that was able to give us that
staircase we couldn't we had to have a
circuit he was there for the very start
of this renovation journey yes even
before HGTV got involved we got an
exclusive tour when the house was first
put on the market last July the home was
listed at 1.8 million dollars
HGTV swooped it up for a cool 3.5
million is it true that this house is
the second most photographed house house
in the White House
clearly 307 days later the restoration
is complete many of the original details
had to be crowd-sourced from fans
somebody had the actual toaster from the
kitchen so the master bedroom yeah yeah
you remember the hole the bed on the
headboard
there was a bust of a woman and it was
like a little white figurine someone who
had that same figurine in their house so
when you see the master bedroom
you'll see that white figurine now we
have to go to one other spot that when
you walk in here it literally takes your
breath away
the stairs do you guys actually remember
that day and tell me what you remember
about it being on that staircase [ __ ]
well we've been on this staircase many
times they're like five iterations we
would take a picture each year so it was
always the account I kind of claimed we
did well the new staircase looks just
like that groovy 70s one that was the
focal point of the Bradys living room
one of the biggest problems we had with
with nine people in the cast was how do
you stage them so that you can see
everybody's faces and the staircase
answered the question but in the real
live house there was no long staircase
it actually was a smaller split-level
version right next to the front door
Marine Marcia Brady yourself help
demolish it when you built the staircase
you build it from scratch
but you made it look 50 years old
exactly and I mean you can't buy a
staircase like that the other thing
that's interesting is that staircase
technically wasn't to code for today's
standards oh we had to modify it so that
it passed inspection we had to add some
plexiglass panels child safety until
then secret can you go anywhere now
without people think hey hey Marshall
hey James hey Peter I feel like we have
friends everywhere we go yeah people
will pick up the conversation
mid-sentence like so how's it going yeah
you know they've known you forever ever
[Music]
no these classic moments live on and
reruns and when they'd shoot interior
scenes on a soundstage well the
staircase led to nowhere
we go up the stairs and we would all
just hide in the hallway up there and
flirt and whatever it was like our time
alone which was awesome and they'll see
us yeah but how it leads somewhere and
now and do that same exact yard there
are a lot of memories in this backyard
it's where the swing set was and where
the boys tossed that infamous football
your nose is beautiful now by the way
thank you so much is that tiger's
doghouse over the tiger doghouse that's
the teeter-totter Susan Cindy and Mike
Bobby were responsible for this
renovation including building tiger's
doghouse and remember the fake grass
that you used to get mowed well that's
there too
how does it feel being out here and
looking at how they recreated things out
in the backyard well it makes me want to
go in tiger's doghouse or get on the
teeter-totter or do a potato sack race
and this is a part that's better because
we were never outside when we were
outside like 40 different shadows around
us and now it's actually under the sky
you know and and we had to compromise
the backyard quite a bit because the
footprint of this this is all new
[Music]